oh this guy is absurd dude this guy  don't disgrace the god like that today  I'm  gonna steroids  but is that really a bad [ __ ] thing I  got cursed in here I got a question for  you would you prefer to see  a dick hanging lower than the balls or  [ __ ] balls hanging lower than the  dick [ __ ] lower than the balls of  course some guys are blessed and have  big [ __ ] dicks and some guys are  [ __ ] and have little [ __ ]  dicks I love that like you know his  content manager or something like that  was like all right we need a video idea  and he's like I got something there was  no content manager bro Rich Piana was  like put that [ __ ] camera got some  [ __ ] I got it we're talking about small  nuts I saw a comment about small nuts  imma [ __ ] fix this right now dude